Traductor: Carmen de Miguel-Murado
Revisor: Penny Martínez
(Sonido de timbre de colegio)
¿Os resulta familiar este sonido, verdad?
Seguro.
Es la señal que indica
que profesores y alumnos
tenemos que salir pitando
de una clase para entrar en otra.
Pasados unos minutos reina la calma
y cada profesor se encuentra
en "su" aula, con "sus" alumnos,
impartiendo "su" asignatura.
Pasan 50 minutos y se repite la historia:
suena el timbre y alumnos y profesores
salen corriendo a los pasillos,
llenos de gente, y así
durante siete horas al día.
De tal forma, que cada alumno tiene
que ponerse en distinto modo
según la hora que sea:
si suena el timbre y
toca la clase de biología,
te tienes que poner en modo "biología",
y en ese momento te ves aprendiendo
el proceso de la fotosíntesis, por ejemplo
¡Ostras! pero suena el timbre,
el dichoso timbre,
y dejas de estar en biología
y te vas a clase de dibujo,
y te pones en modo "dibujo",
y te encuentras allí con unos pinceles
haciendo los colores secundarios.
Y así va pasando el tiempo.
Y esos timbres, esas carreras
y ese ponerse en modo ON
era así hace 50 años, hace 20 y hoy mismo.
Y si traducimos los cuatro años
de la ESO en días, son 720.
5040 horas conviviendo
con el dichoso timbre.
Pero así es como enviamos
la información a los alumnos
y como ellos empaquetan el conocimiento,
en parcelas aisladas, en trocitos.
En 1º de la ESO se empaqueta así,
en 2º de la ESO se empaqueta así,
y en 3º y en 4º,
de tal forma que cuando un alumno
o una alumna titula en 4º de la ESO
podemos decir que tienen en su cabecita
5040 paquetitos de conocimiento,
muy valiosos en sí mismos, pero
sin ningún tipo de conexión entre sí.
Esto también ocurre
en los claustros de profesores.
Somos decenas de docentes,
cada uno de una especialidad,
pero que tanto la información
que enviamos a los alumnos,
como la que muy de vez en cuando
intercambiamos con los compañeros,
es también de parcela a parcela.
Yo, de Dibujo, hablo
con el de Inglés, etc.
Y siempre hablamos de "mi" aula,
con "mis" alumnos y "mi" asignatura.
Yo llevo muchos años trabajando de profe
y he estado en varios centros,
algunos de ellos muy distintos entre sí,
pero lo que siempre he escuchado
a los profes y que siempre dicen es:
"Es que los chicos de hoy
en día no relacionan".
"¡Claro, es que como no vinculan!"
"Es que estos chicos no conectan".
Pero ¿quién conecta así?
Os voy a enseñar una cosa:
Unas navidades, Papá Noel
me trajo esto, seguro que lo conocéis.
La mitad de los que estamos
aquí somos "vintage",
así que lo tenéis que conocer seguro.
Os lo voy a enseñar y
os traerá tiernos recuerdos.
Es un juego muy sencillo, el Conector 3.
Consiste en una pila de petaca
y dos terminales.
Lo que había que hacer era
buscar entre qué dos conceptos
existía relación de ambas columnas.
Por ejemplo, me pongo aquí en el químico
y puntúo aquí, se enciende la luz roja.
Funciona todavía. Conecté poco.
Una mañana de octubre de hace dos años
me encuentro en "mi" aula, con "mis"
alumnos, impartiendo "mi" asignatura,
y hablaba en ese momento
del S. XVIII a los chicos.
Les hablaba de las pinturas negras,
de Francisco de Goya.
No sé muy bien cómo lo hice,
pero en ese momento se callaron,
aquello que parece que pasó un ángel,
y pude escuchar perfectamente
a mi compañera de historia
que en el aula que tenía junto a mí
hablaba también del S. XVIII
pero desde el punto de vista
de la arquitectura,
y les hablaba además de la construcción
del Museo del Prado y pensé:
¡Qué curioso! ¡Qué coincidencia!
Sonó el timbre, salí de clase y le dije:
"No te puedes imaginar lo que ha pasado:
estaba hablando a los chicos de Goya
y te escuchado a ti hablar
de Juan de Villanueva,
de la reestructuración
urbanística del XVIII.
¡Qué curioso, verdad!"
Y le dije: "Si yo voy a estar hablando
de arte del XVIII en este aula,
y tú de arquitectura en la de al lado,
¿por qué no damos mañana la clase juntas?"
Y me dijo: "¿Pero qué dices mamarracha?
que nos separa un tabique.
¡Un tabique! ¡Pues lo tiramos, no!
A mí de Bilbao, un tabique me dura
- sujeta el cubata, a por ello voy -"
(Aplausos)
La verdad es que nos reímos un ratín
con aquello del tabique.
Se marchó, y yo anduve un par de días
dándole vueltas a aquello, y pensé:
probablemente este tabique de Pladur,
no sea el más complicado de tirar,
los muros difíciles de tirar son
los que tenemos aquí (en la cabeza),
esos sí que son complicados.
Os he traído una imagen
a ver qué os parece.
¿Qué veis ahí? ¿Qué os parece
que está ocurriendo?
Pues tiramos los muros,
aquello que se supone
que no se podía tocar,
y cuanto menos, derribar, lo tiramos.
¿Y sabéis lo que pasó?
No pasó absolutamente nada,
y pasó absolutamente todo lo bueno
que tiene que pasar en educación.
En aparente normalidad, éramos los mismos
alumnos, con los mismos profesores,
la misma aula, las mismas asignaturas,
hasta las mismas mesas verdes y sillas
que llevan 300 años en nuestros centros.
Todo era igual, pero nada
volvió a ser lo mismo.
Dijimos: ¡Se acabó! ¡Adiós a los muros!
Se acabó, adiós a los límites
entre asignaturas,
adiós a los tiempos de 50 minutos,
adiós a los timbres,
y cómo no, y lo más importante:
adiós a trabajar solos.
Decidimos cambiar
nuestra forma de trabajar,
porque nos planteamos:
¿Qué ocurre si rompemos la línea
que separa las asignaturas?,
¿Qué ocurre si rompemos
la línea de conocimiento,
aquélla que marca lo previsible?
¿Y qué puede ocurrir si empezamos
a empaquetar el conocimiento
de una forma distinta?
¿Y si en vez de conectar el conocimiento
por parcelas independientes
lo activamos todo a la vez?
¡Ostras! ¿Y si lo conectamos?
Decidimos cambiar
nuestra forma de dar la clase
y ponernos a trabajar en equipo de verdad.
No ese trabajar en equipo
de cuando estás en clase:
¡Venga chicos!
¡el siguiente trabajo es en equipo!
Siempre ves que un alumno
o una alumna resopla, como diciendo:
"¡Ya estamos otra vez
con los dichosos trabajitos en grupo!
A mí me toca pegarme la paliza
a trabajar, estos tres no van a hacer nada
y al final el profe nos va a poner
la misma nota a todos".
Además los profesores, cuando
pedimos trabajos en equipo,
parece que estuviéramos
castigando a quien lo va a hacer
y premiando a quien ya casi a priori
sabemos que no va a hacer nada.
¡Qué curioso esto de trabajar en equipo!
Precisamente somos los profesores los que
pedimos a los chicos trabajar en equipo,
cuando nunca nos ven a nosotros
trabajar en equipo.
Porque a los profesores jamás nadie
nos enseñó a trabajar en equipo,
pero ni en el cole, ni en el instituto,
ni en la universidad, nunca.
Pues se acabó con eso también.
En mi centro hemos decidido
poner en marcha
lo que hemos llamado
"Profesores y aulas de puertas abiertas".
Y a día de hoy, en mi centro,
las clases son de 120 alumnos:
cuatro grupos de 3º de la ESO
a los que impartimos clase ocho profesores
de siete asignaturas distintas a la vez,
todos juntos.
Los alumnos reciben clase
de lengua castellana y literatura,
geografía e historia, biología y geología,
dibujo, música, inglés y educación física,
todos a la vez.
Y ya no es la clase de mate, ni la clase
de lengua, ni la clase de historia, no.
Ahora es la clase del siglo XI,
o la del Renacimiento,
en la que puedes estar escuchando a la vez
hablar de la peste, de los mecenas,
de Florencia, de Roma,
de Bocaccio, de Dante,
incluso de Copérnico, de Kepler
y hasta de Shakespeare.
Imaginad un momento
que estuviérais en mi clase
el día que hablamos
del siglo XIX, por ejemplo.
Mi compañera de Historia comenzaría
hablando de la 2ª Revolución Industrial
y del imperialismo, de cómo los países
van a otros continentes como el africano,
a rescatar algunos elementos,
como el caucho.
Y mi compañera de Ciencias
explicaría a los chavales
que el caucho fue utilizado para fabricar
los primeros neumáticos de esos vehículos,
los primeros automóviles de la época.
Y yo, que soy de Arte,
les contaré a mis alumnos,
que Monet y Turner no hacen por causalidad
que los protagonistas de sus cuadros sean
las locomotoras, ese invento de la época.
Y tampoco fue casualidad
que los hermanos Lumière
filmaran la primera película
de cine de la historia,
y fuera precisamente
la entrada de una locomotora
en una bonita estación de Francia.
Y gracias al desarrollo químico,
el impresionismo gozó de millones
de colores para poder expresar la luz,
que de otra forma hubiera sido imposible.
Y los compositores dejan
de componer de forma lineal,
y pasan a componer a golpe de impresión.
Y Alejandro Dumas escribe
"La dama de las camelias",
que sirve precisamente de inspiración
a Verdi cuando escribe "La Traviata".
Y también es el momento
de la reivindicación social,
del lugar de la mujer.
Y precisamente esta semilla es recogida
por el arte contemporáneo
de algunas artistas como Barbara Kruger,
que hacen esas imágenes
que algunos conocéis, tan potentes.
Las mujeres dicen: "No, las mujeres
no necesitamos ningún héroe."
Y mi compañera de Inglés habla,
¡cómo no!, de la figura de Virginia Woolf.
Ahora sí, ahora sí profesores
trabajando en equipo de verdad,
profesores que hemos
preparado la clase juntos,
profesores observando a un compañero
en lo que hasta ahora era
una frontera infranqueable:
la puerta del aula.
Esa linde que no se podía traspasar.
Si un compañero está dando clase,
no puedes entrar, profanas lo sagrado.
Y esa sensación de linde y de frontera
también la percibían los alumnos.
Yo recuerdo que el primer día
que dimos clase así,
citamos a los chicos en mi aula de dibujo.
Estábamos charlando los profes
y les vimos llegar: 120.
- ¡Buenos días, chicos! ¡Pasad!
Y no pasaban.
- ¡Venga chicos, pasad!
Y ya digo: "Pero vamos a ver,
¿se puede saber por qué no pasáis?"
Y nos dice una alumna, tímida:
"Profe, ¿qué es lo que nos va a pasar?,
¿hemos hecho algo malo?"
Ocho profes allí.
La jefa de estudios, esperando.
- ¡Venid! ¡Algo malo viene!
Algo malo iba a pasar y,
además, ese era el momento.
Pues en el aparente caos
de esa clase de 128 personas
surgió la magia del conocimiento.
La magia del conocimiento compartido
entre profesores y alumnos
que buscábamos tejer nuevas conexiones
en esto de aprender y de enseñar.
He leído hace pocos días que, según
los últimos informes internacionales,
el 87 % de los docentes españoles
jamás ha entrado en clase
de otro compañero a verlo trabajar.
Y los centros educativos
no deberían ser solo un lugar
en el que aprenden los alumnos,
también debería ser el lugar
en el que aprendemos los profesores.
¿Y cómo aprendemos los profesores?
El mejor maestro de un maestro ¿quién es?
Pues otro maestro.
Y los profes aprendemos observando,
dialogando, discutiendo,
evaluando nuestra práctica docente,
pero, sobre todo, aprendemos compartiendo,
compartiendo conocimiento.
Esto de compartir también tiene tela.
Es como lo de trabajar en equipo.
Yo tengo una niña pequeña.
Y cuando por las tardes
voy con ella al parque,
escucho unas 5000 veces diarias
frases como:
"¡Venga, déjale tu pala verde,
que hay que compartir!
¿Qué te dicen en el cole?
que hay que compartir".
Pero compartir ¿hasta cuando?
En qué momento les decimos
a los hijos o a los alumnos:
"¿Te acuerdas que te enseñé a compartir?
Se acabó, ya no se comparte más.
Ahora viene la vida en serio,
en la que tú trabajas solito
y tú te las apañas".
Preguntamos a los profesores
y charlamos y pensamos:
¿Y si empezamos a compartir,
y hacemos que la docencia
deje de ser una profesión aislada,
y pase a ser
una profesión de colaboración?
Pues pasa exactamente
lo que nos está pasando a nosotros.
Así ves que tiene sentido enseñar.
Así sí tiene sentido enseñar.
Y además te ilusionas trabajando,
porque aprendes mucho de tus compañeros,
y casi no te ves trabajando de otra forma.
Y sobre todo que te has dado cuenta
de que te encanta trabajar en equipo,
que no está tan mal, que te gusta.
Y trabajando en la clase de esa forma
ves que los alumnos conectan,
y Javi, mi Javi, con ese pedazo
de ojos verdes que tiene,
que tenéis que conocerlo,
ese alumno que estuvo durante
meses sin venir a clase,
y al que yo personalmente
tuve que ir a su casa,
llamar al timbre y decir:
"Haz el favor de bajar y
venirte conmigo al instituto,
porque tienes que acabar 4º de la ESO
por lo civil o por lo penal".
Y ese Javi levanta la mano y exclama:
"¡Ah, claro, profe, ahora lo entiendo!".
¡Eureka! Ahí está la luz roja del Conecta.
Ahí está.
Y ahora estamos en un 95 %
de titulados en la ESO.
Ahí están esos exámenes maravillosos,
en los que sin darse cuenta
están manejando términos
históricos, artísticos y científicos,
casi sin apreciarlo.
Y ahí están sus respuestas
cuando les preguntamos:
¿por qué ahora sacáis mejores notas?.
Y nos dicen que ahora recuerdan mejor.
Y no es que recuerden mejor,
es que han conectado conocimiento.
Y ese conocimiento que
los profes les damos,
y ese conocimiento que ellos adquieren,
es el andamiaje fundamental
de la educación, pero lo fue siempre,
lo es y lo será,
por mucho que haya
algunos por ahí que digan
que como toda la información
está en la red, a golpe de un clic,
el conocimiento no es tan importante.
En mi centro cambian aproximadamente
al año a la mitad del profesorado.
La mitad de los profes se van
en julio a otros centros.
Al resto de profes los veo todos los días,
de todas las mañanas,
de todo el ciclo lectivo.
Pasan por la puerta de jefatura,
ahí estoy yo.
¡Buenos días, Ana! ¿Qué tal?
A ver qué tal los chicos hoy.
¡Venga, buen día!
Y salvo alguna ocasión muy, muy esporádica
yo no vuelvo a hablar con ellos.
El día a día es una apisonadora
que pasa por encima de todos
nosotros, a nivel burocrático,
y que anula cualquier posibilidad
y espacio para el diálogo.
Y es ahora en julio, cuando vienen
a verme, a despedirse de mí,
a decirme que se van
a otros institutos a trabajar,
cuando en esos cinco o seis minutos
que tengo para charlar con ellos
me entero de que son expertos
en cosas alucinantes.
La profesora de Física y Química me decía
que durante muchísimos años
ha trabajado en el CERN, en Suiza, en
el Centro Europeo de Investigación Nuclear
La trabajadora social es una actriz
muy reconocida en los teatros
de la Gran Vía de Madrid.
El profe de Educación Física ha sido
seleccionador de un equipo español
y ha participado en unos Juegos Olímpicos.
Y yo, la jefa de estudios,
he sido la última en enterarme.
Y pienso: precisamente me entero
ahora, cuando ya se van,
con todo lo que podríamos
haber aprendido de todos de ellos.
En los centros educativos,
los claustros de profes son oro puro.
Tenemos escritores, artistas,
ingenieras, arquitectas,
antropólogos, físicos, químicas.
Oro puro conviviendo
un montón de horas al día,
sin ningún tipo de conexión
entre nosotros.
Yo os voy a contar mi secreto del año:
este año me he propuesto
como objetivo casi vital, profesional,
que estos profes nuevos que han llegado
ahora, hace tres semanas, al instituto,
- están un poco asustados por el método,
pero ya veréis qué chulo es -
Vayan pasando por mi mesa de uno en uno.
Dos preguntas te va a hacer
la jefa de estudios:
Dime quién eres y qué sabes hacer.
Porque estoy convencida de que
vamos a aprender muchísimo de ti.
Ya os contaría si tuviera tiempo,
pero tengo uno que me va a enseñar
a hablar chino que me viene "in love"
(Risas)
y alguno que me ha comentado
cosas que sabe hacer,
pero efectivamente creo
que tampoco se puede decir aquí.
(Risas)
En una era en la que estamos,
en un mundo de fronteras abiertas,
de apertura constante al exterior y de
intercambio de información en las redes.
No puede ser que el conocimiento
siga encerrado entre cuatro paredes
y las puertas bien cerradas,
no puede ser.
Abramos las asignaturas, abramos
las aulas y abramos las puertas,
y contémonos todo lo bueno que se hace
en los centros educativos de este país,
y solo entonces, por fin, podremos hablar
de "nuestras" aulas, "nuestros" alumnos
y "nuestras" asignaturas.
Y gracias a trabajar de esta forma,
conectando, ocurren cosas maravillosas.
Y este pasado mes de junio teníamos a Javi
al piano, tocando una pieza barroca,
que teníais que haberlo visto, porque
ha comprendido lo que es el barroco,
y sus expresiones: las artes, la música,
la literatura, también la ciencia,
y ya siempre dando la clase
con la puerta abierta,
que entre y salga quien quiera,
el conocimiento es para todo el mundo.
Deseando que al día siguiente
continúe esta maravillosa aventura locura
de seguir aprendiendo y enseñando juntos.
Y se levanta de la silla
con un pedazo de sonrisa,
porque hoy por fin, hemos podido decirle
que se ha graduado de 4º de la ESO,
contra todo pronóstico personal,
porque él jamás se vio capaz
de sacar 4º de la ESO.
Contra todo pronóstico
también familiar y también social,
y se acerca a mí y me dice:
"Profe, de esta clase salgo con intriga".
Y yo, que soy de las que a veces
estoy en clase con ellos
y es que lloro de risa por las cosas
que dicen y las cosas que hacen,
no puedo evitar llorar de emoción,
porque en ese instante,
en ese preciso instante,
soy consciente de lo afortunada que soy
de tener la profesión
más bonita del mundo.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)